it's not often that I go to FoxNews to
illustrate non-sarcastic points or go to
FoxNews to illustrate a serious
political point or news reporting
reality but yesterday we had this
absolutely horrific stock market crash
which was so bad that even Fox News had
to cut away from Donald Trump bragging
about the economy to cover the
precipitous crash of the stock market
and if you're not up to speed on the
fact the last two stock market trading
days and so far early today as well mate
might might have changed by the time you
hear this later today it has been an
absolute disaster last Friday in the
middle of the release of the memo fiasco
which of course ended up being a total
nothing burger as I told you yesterday
uncertainty ramped up the Dow lost about
666 points now why am I talking only
about the Dow we'll hold on I'll get to
that because I know that's been a
question for many people in the audience
and yesterday once again the stock
market crashing down as much as 1,600
points in one day which was about 5%
ultimately ending the day down 1175
points which was the biggest single day
decline in points in history but of
course we need to adjust for inflation
to find out whether it's the biggest
real decline and of course the Dow is an
average not an index but in any case the
biggest single point decline during the
2008 financial meltdown the biggest
single day decline was 778 points this
is a 50% bigger decline than the biggest
previous one which was during the 2008
economic crisis now Trump at the time
that this was taking place happened to
have gone to Blue Ash Ohio to brag about
how great the economy was as well as
calling Democrats treasonous and a whole
bunch of other stuff and while the
president is bragging about the great
economy the crash starts and even Fox
News had to cut away check this out
bergen's and thanks to your tax cuts we
see continued success in the future
we're interrupting for breaking news
there is a quite a drop happening on
Wall Street a massive sell-off is
happening today moments ago we were down
more than 900 points on the session
right three and a half percent and it
got WAY worse that was early in the
crash and really just bad optics for
Trump right we have a picture that we're
gonna put up on the screen with the
title Trump tells Sachs sells tax plan
at Ohio factory this is from MSNBC and
then you see on screen at the same time
a bug following the down movement Dow
plunges down 792 points at this time and
here is Donald Trump again calling
Democrats treasonous as the stock market
collapses before our eyes and you have
the other side even on positive news
really positive news like that they were
like death and an American an American
somebody's a treasonous I mean yeah I
guess why not can we call that treason
why not yeah I mean they certainly
didn't seem to love our country very
much so first of all I want to take this
stock market crash in pieces number one
let's debunk the idea that the left is
cheering this I started watching
coverage of this yesterday and you had
all sorts of right-wingers saying it is
horrible that the left is happy that
there was a precipitous market decline
two days in a row I don't know anyone on
the Left that's cheering this I lost as
a result of this what to me is a
significant amount of money I'm not
cheering it I'm not hearing the fact
that the retirement accounts of both
Democrats and Republicans alike are
suffering because because of this I'm
not cheering it I'm not surprised
because ultimately the empty run-up of
the stock market was going to fall at
some point because the underlying
economic principles of the Trump White
House are not economically stimulative
but no I'm not cheering and I'm not
rooting against the American economy and
I don't know anyone on the Left Pat
that's happy about this I mean we may
not support specific Trump or Republican
policy
but the economy at large of course we
want that to succeed of course it is so
much is riding on this and whether
you're a Democrat or a Republican you
want a strong economy I move rooting for
the removal of a terrible steward of the
American economy and Donald Trump that's
number one so now let's go through the
layers of this first of all there's
people saying to me rightly so David
hold on you've always said the Dow isn't
a good overall representative of the
stock market and the stock market isn't
the be-all end-all of the economy well
yeah let's take those one by one the Dow
is an average not an index and of only
thirty companies so I think we have to
look past the Dow unfortunately the
Nasdaq which has the biggest tech stocks
in it and the S&P 500 which is a much
broader index of companies also got
crushed on Friday and yesterday the Dow
dropped got the attention as it often
does but the broader markets were also
down significantly now part two is is
the stock market really a good indicator
of how the economy is doing and as I've
said before it's one part but it's what
Trump has been pointing to to tout a
great economy even though Trump really
hasn't done much that would justify a
such such a huge market run-up Trump has
said because the markets have increased
I'm doing well and conflating the stock
market with the economy was problematic
to begin with but if Trump believes that
the strength of the economy is in the
stock market and if he believes that the
stock market's ran up because of him
then it only follows that the decline is
also both his fault and indicative of a
worsening economy now I was wondering
how is the White House going to react to
this and of course Trump didn't mention
it silence from the White House except
when Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked
about it she said listen the day-to-day
changes in the stock market have never
really been a focus of the
administration except for Trump on
dozens of occasions pointing to a new
record high in the stock market other
than that you mean Sarah it's not been a
focus of the administration and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders could be right in the
sense that this could just be a simple
correction and in the next coming days
the stock market in the Dow Jones could
go
back up sure but you never really know
the stock market Epson flows and we
haven't really seen a crash this big
arguably since the Great Recession of
2008 2009 2010 and who knows how Trump
would handle a poor economy yeah I don't
know I mean I think he would try to
blame someone else right either
Democrats who aren't working with them
or something left over from Obama or
whatever and the same alt rightists who
have been touting the increased stock
market to to sort of cheer Donald
Trump's prowess with the economy are now
jumping all board all aboard the
conspiracy train and that's what I want
to talk about next the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership